- [Voiceover] Try to evaluate
the following integral.
So assuming you've had a go at it,
so let's work through this together.
And if at any point you get inspired,
always feel free to pause the video
and continue on with it on your own.
So the first thing that
might have jumped out at you
we have a rational expression.
The degree in the numerator is the same as
the degree in the nominator,
so maybe a little bit
of algebraic long division is called for.
So let's do that.
Let's take X-squared minus one
and divide it into X-squared,
put that in a different color,
divide it into X-squared
plus X minus five.
So X-squared plus X minus five.
And so let's look at
the highest degree terms
how many times does
X-squared go into X-squared?
It goes one time, let me
write this in a new color.
Goes one time.
One times X-squared minus
one is just going to be
X-squared minus one.
Now you subtract this
green expression from
this mauve expression or I could just add
the negative on it, so let me just take
the negative of it.
So it's going to be
negative X-squared plus one
and we're going to get the X-squared's
X-square minus X-square is zero,
so those cancel out and
we're going to be left with
X and the negative five
plus one is negative four.
So we have X minus four left over.
So we can rewrite the
expression that we're trying to
find the antiderivative of.
We can rewrite it as one plus X minus four
over X-squared minus one.
Maybe I'll do that in that purple color
since I already used it as the purple.
Over X-squared minus one.
So we did one thing, now
we have a lower degree
in the numerator than we
have in the denominator.
And obviously this is
fairly straight forward,
take the antiderivative of,
but what do we do now?
It's not clear if we look
at X-squared minus one
it's derivative would be two-X,
which is the same degree as this,
but it's not X minus four,
so it doesn't look like
you u-substitution it's
going to help us with this.
So what can we do now?
Now we can take out another tool in our
algebraic tool kit, we will do
partial fraction expansion.
Which is essentially
writing this as the sum
of two rational expressions that have
a lower degree in the denominator.
So what do I mean by that?
So this term right over here,
X minus four over X-squared minus one,
we can rewrite that as
X minus four over, instead
of X-squared minus one,
we can factor this.
This is X plus one times X minus one.
So let's write that,
this is X plus one times X minus one.
When we think about
partial fraction expansion
we say okay, can we write this as the sum
of something, let's call
that A, over X plus one,
plus something else, let's call that B,
plus B over X minus one.
Can we do that?
And to attempt to do
that, if we had just add
these two things, what would we get?
Well we would find a common denominator,
which would be X plus
one times X minus one,
and so you would have, if
any of this looks unfamiliar
I encourage you to review the videos
on partial fraction
expansion, because that's
exactly what we're doing right over here.
But this would be equal to
if you were to add the two
your common denominator
would be the product.
So it would be X plus
one times X minus one.
So the first term I would
multiply the numerator
and the denominator times X minus one.
So it would be A times X minus one
plus B, the second term I'll multiply the
numerator and the
denominator times X plus one.
And so what do we get?
This is going to be equal to AX,
maybe I'll do this all in one color.
This is going to be equal to
AX minus A plus BX plus B
and then all of that
over this stuff we keep
writing over and over again.
Actually, let me just copy and paste this.
So copy and paste, I can use
that over and over again.
So we have that over that.
So let's see, now we
can group the X terms.
So we can rewrite this as,
so if we take AX plus BX
that's going to be A plus B times X.
Then we have a negative A and a B.
So plus B minus A, and I'll
just put parenthesis around that
just so I kind of group
these constant terms.
Then all of that's going to be divided by,
good thing I copied and pasted that,
X plus one times X minus one.
So now this is the crux of
partial fraction expansion.
We say, okay we kind of went through this
whole exercise on the thesis
that we could do this,
that there is some A and
B for which this is true.
So if there is some A and
B for which this is true,
then A plus B must be the coefficient
of the X term right over here.
So A plus B must be equal to one,
must be equal to this coefficient.
And B minus A must be
equal to the constant,
must be equal to negative four.
Or if they are then we
will found an A and a B,
so let's do that.
I'll do it up here since I have
a little bit of real estate.
A plus B is going to be equal to one,
and B minus A or I could write that
as negative A plus B is
equal to negative four.
We could add the left hand sides
and add the right hand sides
and then the A's would disappear.
We would get two B is
equal to negative three
or B is equal to negative three halves.
We know that A is equal to one minus B,
which would be equal to
one plus three halves,
since B is negative three halves,
which is equal to five halves.
A is equal to five halves.
B is equal to negative three halves.
And just like that we
can rewrite this whole
integral in a way that
is a little bit easier
to take the anti or this whole expression
so it's easier to integrate.
So it's going to be the integral of
one plus A over X plus one.
A is five halves and so I
could just write that as,
let me write it this way,
five halves times one over X plus one.
I wrote it that way because
it's very straight forward
to take the antiderivative of this.
Then plus B over X minus one.
Which is going to be
negative three halves.
So I'll just write it
as minus three halves
times one over X minus one.
That was this right over here, DX.
Notice all I did is I took this expression
right over here and I did a little bit
of partial fraction expansion
into these two, I guess
you could say, expressions
or terms right over there.
It's fairly straight
forward to integrate this.
Antiderivative of one,
it's just going to be X.
Antiderivative of five
halves, one over X plus one,
is going to be plus five halves,
the natural log of the
absolute value of X plus one.
We're able to do that
because the derivative
of X plus one is just
one, so the derivative
is there so that we can
take the antiderivative
with respect to X plus one.
You could also do
u-substitution like we've done
in previous examples, U
is equal to X plus one.
And over here, this is going
to be minus three halves
times the natural log
of the absolute value
of X minus one, by the
same exact logic with how
we were able to take the
antiderivative there.
And of course we cannot
forget our constant.
And there we have it.
We've been able to integrate, we were able
to evaluate this expression.